vous avez rejoint eric zemmour oui à la
surprise générale enfin plus une
surprise un moment mais à la surprise
générale pourquoi irais xénon
bas parce que je me suis retrouvé sur le
plan des convictions avant tout je pense
que personne il n'aura échappé à
personne que j'avais des divergences de
ligne de stratégie depuis longtemps avec
le rassemblement national est d'ores et
déjà je les exprime et quand j'étais à
l'intérieur du mouvement et que je vois
un exe moore bombal à l'incarnation
finalement de ce rassemblement à droite
que j'appelle de mes voeux depuis
longtemps je le vois d'ores et déjà dans
ses équipes je le vois dans son
potentiel électorat je le vois également
en potentiel
si les qualifier au deuxième tour est
bon pour toutes ces raisons je crois que
c'est là où je devais être et où je
crois à la victoire et est ce que vous
avez des nouvelles normes de marine le
pen ça ça me regarde pas assis à genoux
et on se dit noël ça va 16 mai base et
madonna ben non ça ça vous regarde
passer les histoires personnelles donc
ça veut dire oui comment ça veut dire
oui bah vous en déduisez ce que vous
voulez mais je veux pas parler de ma vie
familiale et personnalisée par le
politique c'est un d'abord un sujet
politique c'est pas une histoire de
famille là le sujet alors donc vous avez
rejoint eric zemmour on va parler de
quel droit tu pour quelle france c'est
le thème puisque vous êtes toutes les
deux de droite mais pas tout à fait la
même ce que dit valérie pécresse la
droite c'est moi eric zemmour et marine
le pen se sont disqualifiés par leur
complicité avec vladimir poutine c'est
quelque chose que vous reprenez que très
souvent valérie pécresse et marion
maréchal eric zemmour a cette capacité à
rassembler à droite il a brisé ce fameux
cordon sanitaire de la droite qui
empêchait la victoire on est parti sur
ce thème parce que c'est vrai que il ya
trois très gros candidats à droite et
c'est vrai qu'à un moment il n'y en aura
qu'un qu'il sera qualifié donc là c'est
le moment de savoir quel droit tu vois
là vous allez choisir entre la droite de
marion maréchal eric zemmour est celle
de valérie pécresse qu'on a vu celle de
marine le pen la semaine dernière marion
maréchal petit moi pourquoi il faut
choisir pour vous eric zemmour plutôt
valérie pécresse
non pas pour une raison simple et
d'ailleurs j'aimerais pouvoir vous
interpellez madame ce sujet là et moi je
vous rassure je suis pas du tout dans
une logique de combat de boxe c'est pas
l'idée que je me fais de la politique
donc je pense qu'on a des vraies
divergences vous les assumez je les
assume donc c'est l'occasion justement
d'en parler aujourd'hui et c'est vrai
qu'à ce titre on vous parlait à
l'instant de la phrase d'emmanuel macron
alors je veux bien entendre de sa part
une forme de stratégie mais c'est vrai
qu'on a d'un certain nombre d'indicés
comprenez qui crée une forme de trouble
à la fois sur le fait que vous aviez dit
le 16 mars qu'il avait repris une grande
partie de votre programme même si vous
avez ensuite un peu changé le discours
de ce point de vue là il y a dans vos
équipes au sein de l air aujourd'hui des
gens qui d'ores et déjà se projette dans
des alliances avec emmanuel macron vous
aviez vous même appelé à voter pour lui
en 2017 donc c'est vrai que
il ya aujourd'hui une forme de
d'ambiguïté que je vois bien que vous
souhaitez le vc ça je vous pose la
question très directement parce que je
n'ai jamais vraiment entendu la réponse
est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
aujourd'hui vous n'appellerait pas à
voter emmanuel macron dans tous les cas
de figure si vous n'êtes pas qualifier
au second tour sans me faire la réponse
habituelle s'il vous plaît de mais de
toute façon je serai qualifiée donc la
question ne se posait pas parce que je
pense qu'il ya un besoin de
clarification que c'est simplement ça
mais madame maréchal
cette question elle ne se pose pas on
peut pas mais on peut pas aller dans une
élection en pensant qu'on n'est pas
qualifié au second tour ça mais ça n'est
pas possible mais ça n'existe pas c'est
pas psychologiquement possible les
français qui m'écoutent aujourd'hui ils
se demandent est-ce qu'elle va être au
second tour est-ce qu'elle a la volonté
est ce qu'elle à l'énergie est-ce
qu'elle a la carrure c'est ça qui se
pose comme question c'est pas qu'est ce
qu'elle va faire si elle perd
franchement j'entends les cds grecs est
selon toi bats pas normal parce qu'il ya
une ambiguïté ou un reproche qui peut
vous êtes fait pourquoi voulu clarifier
pas tous un mur y'a plein de candidats
qui ont répondu à cette question moi
même j'ai dit voilà si l'examen était
pas qualifie mois mais attendez j'ai
compris que ça donne le sentiment de
voyez ce que je veux dire ne pas vouloir
de vous échapper c'est ça qui est un peu
trop les matadors je vais vous dire on
m'a posé cette question plusieurs fois
dans plusieurs couleurs parce qu'on est
pris aux régionales nommé aux régionales
quand on me disait que j'allais pas
gagné et c'est aux législatives à chaque
fois on pose cette question jamais
jamais je n'ai répondu à une telle
question donc c'est pas parce que c'est
vous qui me la poser c'est pas parce que
c'est aujourd'hui c'est pas mal non mais
c'est pas de problème je le jugerai le
sujet répond pas d'accord non en
revanche je comprends pas pourquoi parce
que je vois pas pourquoi vous qui passez
beaucoup de temps et je le conçois parce
que je le partage à dire que le bilan
des manuels macro est dramatique c'est
un mauvais président pour la france que
justement votre candidature se justifie
en réponse emmanuel macron je comprends
pas pourquoi vous pouvez pas tout
simplement dire jamais je voterai pour
emmanuel macron enfin c'est ça devrait
être naturel mais c'est parce que je
vais le remplacer dans tous les cas de
figure ce que je vais le remplacer à
d'accord et c'est moi je serai mairie
c'est vrai que
je dis ce que dit ma marion maréchal
dirais que c'est une question qu'on se
pose tous après voilà si les cas de
figure et si par exemple voilà ces voix
là comme la les sondages le disent pour
l'instant c'est marine le pen face à m
que ce soit par sanwi quelques séances
géré 6006 mathis et fabien roussel face
à dire je veux être à ça ça me parle et
on verra le jour venu qui sera en fait
maintenant et je vous dis que ce sera
moi et je vous dis je serai là surprise
il avait déjà fait une fois vos poils
aux fins de les badges genève où il dit
bon oui mais peut-être que on peut
mentionner à passer à autre chose parce
que moi je voudrais vous interdisez
intéressant je songerai vous avez
sélectionné fracture quand même oui il
ya une vraie ligne de fracture et la
turn my sur un mois entre macro et moi
c'est pour ça que vous nous oppose la
vision de la france de pâques la rue la
vision de la france lui il veut il voit
une france
communautariser moi je vois une nation
une et indivisible lui dit il ya des
cultures en france moi je vois une seule
culture française il veut des
commencerez c'est une foire de mâcon et
moi venons juste plus valérie pécresse
marion maréchal c'est un soutien d'eric
zemmour dont nous parlons d'eric zemmour
eux aussi les parents d'élèves à la cub
c'est vrai je le dis j'ai un vrai
problème avec marion maréchal et son
mentor eric zemmour un vrai problème
c'est l'heure c'est leur proximité
aujourd'hui avec vladimir poutine quand
vous avez dit ah bah vous avez dit que
vous l'admirent y est que voulant venger
pas tout à fait de ses généraux un
géostratège phénoménal je crois même que
vous avez dit que vous aviez envie un
taux de déchet vous aimeriez déjeuner
avec alors ça tombe bien parce que il se
trouve que moi j'ai déjeuné trois fois
avec lui quand j'étais ministre nous les
gardiens se lit en effet et je le
connais les primes je le connais je le
connais j'allais dire politiquement et
je sais qu'une seule chose c'est que il
ne respecte que le rapport de force et
il ne veut pas le bien de la france il
veut une france à genoux il veut pas une
france debout et quand ils envoient les
milices wagner en centrafrique ou au
mali pour déstabiliser nos troupes et
nos hommes je peux vous dire que c'est
pas un ami de la france qu'on a en face
et moi quand on est amis ou fasciné par
vladimir poutine rem on est
décrédibilisé pour président mandela
pendant les sons marion maréchal et
ouais pour réponse en mai juste question
répond précédent mais je vais répondre
attendu juste que vous allez marion non
simplement moi je pense que c'est un
c'est un pro c'est un peu facile à faire
à rebours parce qu'en réalité il n'a
jamais été question de complicité ou de
soumission et je pense que tout le monde
peut admettre aujourd'hui que le
vladimir poutine qu'on a en face de nous
et pas de la dîmière côtier ya quelques
années d'ailleurs vous me parlez de
mentors vous votre mentor c'est jacques
chirac je me trompe pas celle-ci -
jacques chirac et jacques chirac lui a
remis la légion d'honneur c'était avant
la guerre en ukraine en lisant le
jacques chirac lui a remis la légion
d'honneur la légion d'honneur donc vous
voyez bien que les choses ne sont pas si
sens que vous même vous aviez reçu en
2000 vous aviez posé nicolas sarkozy lui
même à de très nombreuses reprises a dit
qu'il ne fallait pas diaboliser la
russie il ne fallait pas diaboliser la
lumière poutine ait accepté le pardon le
dialogue entre d'un côté l'union
européenne et la russie moi je n'ai pas
dit autre chose donc je trouve que c'est
un peu facile aujourd'hui de venir
comment dire ceux utilisés cet argument
pour expliquer qu'il y aurait les
mauvais patriotes français et les bons
patriotes français moi je crois qu'il
n'y a pas d'ambiguïté là dessus
aujourd'hui eric zemmour d'ailleurs est
très claire dans sa condamnation de la
russie dans son sa volonté de maintenir
le dialogue et surtout ce dont j'ai du
mal à comprendre dans ce dans ce
reproche c'est ce qu'il induit ça veut
dire que vous demain si vous êtes élue
présidente de la république on est
d'accord que vous allez garder le lien
avec vladimir poutine vous allez
continuer à discuter avec lui vous allez
continuer à avoir une comment dire une
démarche diplomatique à son égard pour
pouvoir défendre les intérêts de l'union
européenne et de la france je me trompe
pas des relations diplomatiques bien sûr
tellement d'accord et comme la france
avait des relations diplomatiques avec
staline mais cela n'empêchait pas le
traiter comme un dictateur il met on pas
ce que c'est un dictateur vous êtes bien
d'accord mais eux vérifier moi qui lui
remit les stadiers nord s'améliorent
mentor oui enfin en chine et moi à une
période où c'était paribas wt cela c'est
ce que vient d'ailleurs madame non mais
est-ce que vous admettez au célèbre
docteur aujourd'hui là parce que eric
zemmour l'admets pas il refuse de dire
le magic tateurs elle c'est un diktat
mais oui mais moi j'ai pas de problème
si oui on peut se battre sur les mots si
vous voulez un vrai filon c'est un
régime autoritaire dans lesquelles les
libertés sont pas respectées donc moi
j'ai aucun problème avec ça c'est un
deal inhalateur non mais c'est si vous
voulez c'est un dictateur c'est sam
alors c'était un diktat jamais aucun
problème avec ça dans ce qu'il ait
changé d'avis sur lui c'est que non non
j'ai pas changé d'avis du tout que j'ai
dit que parce que vous me parlez de
l'histoire de ce dîner on peut en parler
si vous voulez moi j'avoue que avoir
l'occasion de savoir ce qu'il ya dans la
tête de vladimir poutine ça m'intéresse
j'ai pas dit que je souhaitais ça
meilleure amie ou aller en boîte de nuit
avec lui c'est pas le c'est pas le sujet
si vous voulez non mais bon parce que
c'est un très bon danseur non mais je
suis d'accord avec vous mais si vous
voulez une fois que vous êtes allé sur
ce terrain sémantique parce que vous
faites comme les journalistes de gauche
vous adorez vous battre sur les mots une
fois que vous avez dit ça qu'est ce que
vous en ramenant l'extrême droite sinon
est-ce que je suis pas d'extrême droite
qu'est ce que vous en concluez mada est
à dire qu'est ce que vous en concluez
c'est à dire que demain en tant que
président de la république vous n'allez
plus discuté avec tel ou tel régime
parce que c'est un régime autoritaire ou
un régime dictatorial le souci c'est que
si vous faites cela vous comprenez bien
que votre agenda va s'alléger parce que
malheureusement la plupart des pays du
monde fort malheureusement d'ailleurs ce
soit au moyen-orient ou en afrique
ou dans d'autres régions du monde sont
des régimes qui ne respectent pas les
démocraties les principes démocratiques
tels qu'on les connaît voilà donc moi
tout ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on
peut se positionner sur des postures
morales donner des leçons aux autres
expliqué que ce sont des traîtres à leur
nation la réalité c'est qu'il ya un
enjeu de réalisme et de réalités qui
nous oblige aujourd'hui à vouloir
chercher la paix et garder le dialogue
s'il vous plaît c'est valérie pécresse
et marion répond quand même répondre
là-dessus mais je vais vous dire un truc
les téléspectateurs ce soir ils ont
surtout envie de savoir quelle droite et
la droite d'eric zemmour quelle droite
et la droite de valérie blass et quand
même froid intense et maintenant je me
dis ce qui est le plus important c'est
ça pour l'aider oui mais ce qui est
important c'est quand même de savoir qui
défend les intérêts de la france ma
droite c'est une droite qui défendra
toujours les intérêts de la france est
passée à des milices qui arrive en
centrafrique et qui disent du mal de la
france parce que vous savez que la
france n'a jamais été aussi impopulaire
en afrique aujourd'hui et ça c'est ça
c'est une faute et c'est d'ailleurs un
vrai problème du bilan d' emmanuel
macron parce qu'on n'a pas su mettre en
place une vraie politique de co
développement de l'afrique que moi
j'appelle de mes voeux et que je ferais
si je suis président de la république je
reprendrai l'aide au développement et on
fera vraiment une priorité pour
l'afrique parce que le destin du
continent africain et le destin du
continent européen sont liés et que si
on est impopulaire en afrique et bien
aujourd'hui ce sera ce sera vraiment
quelque chose qui sera très dommageable
à la france donc les milices wagner que
poutine envoyait occultant gas lift à ce
qu'est ce qu'elles font les ministes
wagner et bien elle fonde la campagne
d'information contre la france et comme
emmanuel macron est allé à moscou il a
laissé vladimir poutine faire une
conférence de presse et la laisser dire
sans rien dire que les milices wagner
n'étaient pas financés par moscou et ben
moi président de la république je
laisserai pas dire à vladimir poutine
que inc il n'y a pas eu non pas les
intérêts de la france en afrique non
mais c'est l'inertie et
vous auriez pour ça c'est bizarre allez
au maréchal est bâti sur plater mais
vous auriez maintien oui mais c'est un
rapport de force ingénieux la vie de
puissance et ce avec une volée
j'essaye dhabi mais aujourd'hui les
intérêts français pierre de hyères si
toutes les deux mais ce que j'aimerais y
maintient sur presse marion maréchal et
valérie pécresse ça y est on
est d'accord
rien de ce que vous dites siéger ou le
dit les français ils aimeraient bien
passer maintenant à quelle est la
différence entre les deux droit à l'ass
et la droite c'est que ces mots et la
droite valérie perez je sais que vous
êtes passionné mais là c'est vraiment je
sais non mais c'est vrai mais c'est très
bien mais c'est vrai que là on a besoin
de savoir et c'est ça la vraie question
si qu'on se pose ce soir marion maréchal
pour vous est-ce que valérie pécresse
c'est une droite molle
c'est une droite que j'aime à l'ag du
mal à identifier c'est vrai avec
laquelle on a des vraies divergences de
points de vue je pense que là dessus on
peut on peut on peut s'accorder avec des
marqueurs forts notamment qui divergent
et aussi des points de convergence on va
pas les renier totalement non plus alors
c'est vrai que j'ai pas ça moi vous
venez de le dire à l'instant quelqu'un
qui reprend la terminologie de la gauche
pour me qualifier d'extrême droite
j'aimerais bien savoir en quoi je suis
une femme d'extrême droite très
sincèrement d'hébron sas je pense que
c'est une posture habituelle qui vous
permettra demain d'ailleurs d'appeler à
voter emmanuel macron au second tour si
eric zemmour encore vous n'êtes pas une
femme d'extrême droite bas et si vous
voulez vous savez ce que c'est que
l'extrême droite je pense quand même
bruit extrême droite c'est quand même
des régimes totalitaires qui se
raccroche à ceux du 20e siècle avec des
idéologies très particulière et je n'ai
pas le sentiment dans ce qu'on défend
aujourd'hui qu'on ait un quelconque lien
avec non seulement la méthode de
gouvernement qui est défendue mais les
idéologies qui s'y attachent donc c'est
extrêmement insultant et je pense que
c'est une posture facile et c'est
précisément parce que la droite dite
républicaine parlementaire tient ce
genre de discours qu'elle a perdu le
pouvoir depuis maintenant dix ans
qu'elle a permis à des gens comme
emmanuel macron d'être élu et peut-être
et je ne l'espère pas réélu parce
qu'elle a jeté l'opprobe elle a
contribué à jeter l'opprobe sur des
idées patriotique national de
souverainisme en jetant l'opprobre sur
ceux qui la défendent est à l'époque
valérie pécresse moi je regrette des cas
n'est pas qu'elle n'est pas c'est une
question tout ça et je suis extrêmement
affligé une question toute simple mais
on va mais je vous répondrai quand vous
a répondu à ma question toute simple
vous verrez est ce que pour vous islam
et islamisme c'est la même chose comme
dit eric zemmour alors vous savez madame
pécresse que si elle en a mais
islamistes et la même chose et là on a
vraiment s'agit là évidemment
intéressant c'est marrant que vous allez
sur ce débat parce que manifestement
celle qui confond les deux c'est vous
parce que c'est vous qui fréquentaient
des associations radical proche des
frères musulmans du type l'union des
associations musulmanes du 93 qui
allaient dans des écoles coraniques où
il y à des jeunes filles voilées qui
rencontrait mohamed des niches qui était
le recteur de la mosquée de pantin qui a
été engagé vous le savez dans la sphère
de samuel paty et qui est ailleurs été
écartée à ce titre on a fermé la mosquée
a à ce titre à ce titre là manifestement
c'est vous qui faites cette confusion
est qui et qui semble-t-il eu fait
preuve d'une certaine compromission à
leur égard vous est même allé là-bas
d'ailleurs rencontré monsieur une niche
pour dire si je ne m'abuse que vous
étiez favorable au port du voile à
l'université mais rockeur a non pas
n'importe où n'importe quoi à n'importe
quoi mais mais je vous répondrais je
répondrais je pourrais tu sais c'est pas
monsieur est nichée sais pas vous mais
un matin je peux foncer moi avoue avec
les fillettes voilées search ici je vais
vous répondre je peux vous répondre je
peux vous répondre vous avez amené des
documents les jeunes et de youtube si
oui oh oui je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que madame pécresse la fois
dernière a dit que c'était faux déjà à
plusieurs reprises et donc je voulais
pas non mais attendez si dire c'est faux
mais pas de photos de moi j'espère si
c'est pas l'or valérie peisson plus tard
non mais d'abord d'abord évidemment
c'est tout ça et
une manip comme une autre madame se paye
maintenant je vous explique non mais
pardon jeu là je vous ai pas interrompu
mais je vous ai dit aux opérateurs ont
pu s est défait je faisais pas
interrompu donc
j'ai été la première femme politique a
demandé la fermeture de la mosquée de
pantin après l'assassinât tragique de
samuel pâtit la première en dix ans la
mosquée de pantin a une responsabilité
dans les appels à la haine elle doit
être fermé j'étais la première le
deuxième set et manuel valls qu'on a dit
regretter d'avoir une très bonne ligne
même si les niches j'ai coupé tous les
ponts avec lui à qu'en 2015 et non en
2015 nous sommes en 2022 en baisse le
gars qui confondent jarvis guenand
attendent et à des tas d un départ ce
que je me suis rendu compte que cette
personne qui était à l'époque
l'interlocuteur officiel de tous
j'allais dire de toute la classe
politique président de la république pr
min istres ministre de l'intérieur parce
qu'il présidait comme vous l'avez dit
une association qui est l association
des musulmans de seine-saint-denis je
suis élue de seine-saint-denis voilà le
siège de ma région il est en 5 5 dans un
département qui est un département
compliqué où il ya beaucoup mais vous
savez le sujet est ce que monsieur les
niches était président de cette
association le sujet c'est pas est-ce
que je suis allé le rencontrer parce que
comme vous le disiez pour monsieur
poutine quand on est président de la
république on parle à tous les français
et on les rencontre nantes il ya une
grand les rendements des cresnays
attendez je grande différence radio mana
mana je finis dans ce comté a réuni ses
valeurs et manifestants je les ai
rencontrés à une époque où il était une
personne qui était un interlocuteur
officiel quand je me suis aperçu que
cette personne jouer double jeu et vous
savez comment je m'en suis aperçu je me
suis aperçu parce que ils ont monté une
cabale contre moi en essayant de me
faire dire le contraire de ce que
j'avais dit parce que le sujet c'est pas
est-ce que je suis allé les rencontrer c
est ce qu est ce que je leur ai dit le
jour où gervais les ai rencontrés à six
représentants du culte musulman pour le
port de jeu le gardien non à leur idylle
10 mêmes droits mêmes devoirs la loi est
au dessus de la fois est ce qu on a
demandé à nos compatriotes chrétiens et
juifs dans le passé on doit pouvoir le
demander dans les mêmes termes à nos
compatriotes musulmans c'est à dire
d'inscrire leur culte dans les lois de
la république et et il y avait beaucoup
de journalistes ce jour là et ils ont eu
l'honnêteté décrire exactement la vérité
c'est à dire ce que j'avais dit ce jour
là donc c'est ça madame le pen mais si
vous voulez je vous enverrai l'article
parce que moi je suis pas venu que les
articles de journaux ou non mais je vous
enverrai l'article je sais que ce qui
explique exactement ce que j'ai dit ce
jour là je pense qu'on l'a su aller et
je sais tu es à une rupture de jeunes
s'étaient pas c'était à la salle notre
dame du blanc-mesnil d'accord alors y
ont masqué comme une grande différence
excusez moi parce que vous faites une
comparaison avec la russie et
l'association officielle donc de lui
même du 93 mais entre d'un côté être
chefs d'état et être contraint par la
force des choses de pouvoir dialoguer
avec des régimes y compris qui nous
déplaisent pour défendre les intérêts de
l'europe et de la france et se rendre
volontairement à la rupture du jeûne
d'une association dont on savait déjà à
l'époque elle était proche des frères
musulmans mais non et voilà et en faire
le choix est allé faire des déclarations
allô allô l'ordre de celle que vous avez
fait à l'époque les présidents de la
république et les ministres de
l'intérieur tout le monde venait tout le
monde venait de menacer si pas unique
mais le sujet non mais le sujet vous
savez qui avait des convictions et
glissent les nommer le malheureusement
je n'ai pas déjeuné gêné tellement eu
peu de compromis chaque islamisme que
j'ai été à l'origine avec jean françois
copé de la loi sur l'interdiction de la
burqa dans l'espace public j'ai ensuite
quand j'ai été élu était élue présidente
de région fait voter une charte de la
laïcité pour que jamais dans ma région
il ya un euro de subvention qui a la une
association avec des ennemis de la
république et là je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que l'on ait fermé nationale
y est tu vois le front national à
l'époque vous vous en faisiez partie a
refusé de vous défier cette salle
valérie la laïcité et valérie pécresse
mais je vais revenir sur un sur sur un
point on a on a eu l'idée pour vous
marion maréchal et d'extrême droite
moi ce que je comprends je comprends que
madame maréchal elle veut elle veut que
l'extrême droite et la droite fusionnent
voilà et bien moi je lui dis non pour
moi il ya un cordon sanitaire c'est mon
hisser le général de gaulle l'a tracé
ensuite jacques chirac vous abonner à un
cordon sanitaire entre la droite extrême
on n'est pas on n'a pas la même nature
mais elle ne m'a pas répondu sur la sq a
dit eric zemmour ce masque islamisme et
islam c'est la même chose moi je lutte
contre le totalitarisme islamiste et je
lutte pied à pied j'ai mis en place là
encore toujours dans ma région et je le
ferai pour la france des lanceurs dahleb
d'alert dans les clubs sportifs pour
repérer les signes de radicalisation et
je vais présenter une loi
constitutionnelle aux français pour
permettre de lutter encore plus contre
l'islamisme donc est notamment allé
consulter des sites jihadistes par
exemple ce sera un délit les terroristes
islamistes qui sort de prison ils auront
des peines de sûreté de rétention à leur
sortie de prison pour pu être un danger
pour autrui et puis je vais permettre
dans cette loi aux sikhs la
radicalisation puisse être une cause
réelle et sérieuse de licenciement dans
la fonction publique parce que et dans
les entreprises parce qu'ils en ont
besoin je lui tenais à une question il
ya une qui est
concret concrètement madame le pen y'a
les mots ceinture où je fais non sa loge
et moi j'ai une question parce que vous
dites à refuser de vous appeler madame
le pen oui bon madame arlette chabot
j'ai pas de problème mais dans tous les
cas les deux mouvements mais je
m'appelle madame maréchal samar civile
une chose parce que vous expliquer donc
je suis pour allier la droite et
d'extrême droite mais j'aimerais savoir
du coup qu'est ce que vous pensez du
fait que votre propre bras droit eric
ciotti ou le chef de la dae aurait l'air
au parlement européen en l'occurrence
françois xavier bellamy ou d'autres
sénateurs de type etienne blanc ont
expliqué que s'il y avait un deuxième
tour emmanuel macron eric zemmour il
voterait pour eric zemmour sans
hésitation donc je comprends pas ce que
ces gens sont d'extrême droite s kitchen
la compromission avec l'extrême droite
est ce que vous pourriez me répondre là
je ne veux pas vous vous êtes pour moi
vous êtes la division de l'extrême voilà
il ya l'extrême droite c'est marine le
pen et il y avoue qu' qui avait divisé
votre propre famille qui avait quitté
votre tante je crois pas émoussé
l'extrême droite mais il nous arrive de
la fusion il veut que la droite et
l'extrême droite
décomplexée mon île au milieu de marine
le pen et demi il est complice de
l'extrême haute parce qu'il va y aviez
va finir par s'allier il va finir par
voter marine le pen met donc eric gil va
voter à tort alors eric zemmour va voter
marie pelt il a tort
moi j'ai des alliés qui pensent pas
forcément tous comme moi voilà mais le
sujet
est pas le sujet ils sont pas
extrêmement ils sont de droite ils sont
avec moi et d'ailleurs c'est avec moi
qu'il travaille donc en conclusion nous
ne sommes pas d'extrême en avance et là
dessus j'ai dit vous étiez complices de
l'extrême droite parce que ce que vous
allez faire c'est vous alliez avec
marine le pen si je la mets les taux de
vote pour des gens complice de l'extrême
droite potentiellement je sais pas c'est
lui qui dope vous vous mariez mari john
vous étiez donc à l'extrême droite et
donc jamais été à aix en mai quand vous
étiez bas quand vous étiez je considère
pas que même le rasant le national c'est
aujourd'hui des accords parce que là
c'est ce que vous venez de dire toutes
les deux avaient déposé tout ceci
et au milieu et alex émond et après il
ya valérie p je dis pas du tout ça je
dis est ce que eric ciotti qui appelle à
la beauté eric zemmour au second tour
face à emmanuel un coin et d'extrême
urgence laconisme essayez donc charrie
c'était la même version y'a pas
d'extrême droite en france abat en tout
cas elle est pas au rassemblement
national et l epa shihri zemmour ça
c'est absolument excusez-moi bayal sur
la vague des attentes c'est n'importe
quoi on entend
alors je vais vous dire non mais vous
dire le sujet le sujet aujourd'hui êtes
en train de dire que les millions
d'électeurs du rassemblement national
des indépendants d'eric zemmour sont
potentiellement donc des gens d'extrême
droite c'est ça qu'ils attentent moi je
parle pas aux électeurs ah oui donc les
gens qui votent la même chose leur plaît
non les électeurs se poser soit colère
et leurs représentants de colère et ils
peuvent avoir envie de voter pour
l'extrême droite mais c'est l'extrême
droite voilà et c'est possible
extrêmement satisfaisant sur gmail vous
êtes mais pourquoi je ne sais pas y
avait un succès bien sûr est-ce que vous
d'être ce que vous avez d'être d'extrême
droite oui excusez moi c'est une insulte
alors j'ai vraiment attention quand on
vous appelle le pen c'est une insulte
mais quel rapport avec l'extrême droite
dans les rapports entre eux excusez-moi
m quand demain et je vais les laisser la
droite trente ans que jean marie la dre
julie sigouin qui sont quand même
étonnante alors que l'extrême droite
madame non je suis pas d'extrême droite
mais on perd on peut en parler
maintenant mais si vous voulez
islamisme et islam a dit la même chose
répondre en disant cela en disant cela
vous insultez des millions d'électeurs
voilà je vous le dis et je pense que si
aujourd'hui la droite que vous
représentez est aussi disqualifié au
delà du bilan qui a été le sien pendant
40 ans c'est aussi parce que précisément
vous reprenez ses postures morales de la
gauche et vous êtes dans l'insulté
permanente et excusez moi aussi parce
que vous pouvez pas dire vous pouvez pas
prendre les gens pour des idiots en dix
ans excusez moi je finis là dessus en
disant ah mais les électeurs en fait ils
sont pas contents ils sont très très en
colère donc ils votent pour des gens
totalement infréquentable mais en fait
ils sont totalement frais comptables
c'est juste qu'il soit un peu idiot et
que comprennent pas trop ce que disent
leurs représentants pardon mais ces
excuses extrêmement insultant pour eux
mais c'est de connaître un coup d'essai
pas du tout ce que je leur dis pas que
je leur dise et que les vraies solutions
les vraies solutions pour la france
c'est nous qui les avons pas ce que vous
vous allez diviser les français vous
allez dire préférence nationale ça
marchera pas vous allez dire vous nous
disiez migration on peut venir nation
mais
c'est quand même bien j'aimerais qu'on
parle de l'immigration zéro mais ils
vont dire immigration zéro immigration
zéro et ça marchera pas donc vous allez
diviser les français vous allez prendre
des solutions qui vont amener à
l'impuissance moi mes solutions sont les
bonnes mais solution c'est celle qui
vont permettre de limiter l'immigration
incontrôlée avec des quotas migratoires
avec un donnant donnant avec les pays
d'origine où je dis aux pays d'origine
vous reprenez vos clandestins et si vous
les reprenez pas c'est zéro vise à 0
visa de regroupement familial ce héros
visa étudiant 0 visa de travail c'est ça
la solution qui marche aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le sujet s'est pas non même
si j'avais c'est pas de diviser les
français artificiellement de semer la
discorde réguler l'immigration et mais
c'est au contraire reprendre le contrôle
des frontières et ses essais la droite
en tout cas que je représente mes
solutions qui sont les bonnes et 120
jeunes à tous ceux qui sont tentés de
voter pour vous parce que ils attendent
ces solutions concrètes pour lutter
contre l'immigration incontrôlée au
maroc pour remettre de l'ordre dans la
rue pour remettre de l'anarchie valérie
avec les peines-plancher que je propose
alors juste c'est intéressant que vous
rebondissez sur ce terme d' immigration
zéro parce que vous le savez les termes
d'immigration 0 c'est un terme qui
étaient utilisés au moment de les états
généraux l'immigration 90 au moment de
la convention rpr udf et à l'époque il y
avait alain juppé qui tenait un rôle non
négligeable juppé que vous aviez vous
même soutenu d'ailleurs à la primaire de
la droite il était assumée par cette
droite d'aller vers l'immigration zéro
alors depuis évidemment on sait ce qu'il
est advenu tout ay eu une succession de
renoncement et de non-application de ses
promesses mais ce qui me surprend c'est
que vous jouez vous soyez gênée par ce
terme pourquoi parce que l'idée de
l'immigration zéro elle est très simple
en fait c'est tout simplement des
réduire l'émigration partout où elle
peut être réduite et de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait à l'issue du quinquennat
plus de départs que d'entrée de départ
pourquoi ai je vois pas en quoi cela ne
vous choque puisque vous dites j'ai pas
en quoi c'est diviser les français que
de vouloir leur dire aujourd'hui que
tous les fichiers s pour radicalisation
étrangers n'ont pas vocation à rester
sur le territoire s'est gelé des génies
le doubs les délinquants oui ben alors
dans ce cas là en quoi c'est diviser les
français que tous les délinquants et
criminels condamnés étrangers n'ont pas
vocation à rester sur le territoire que
les 25% détenus étrangers dans nos
prisons n'ont pas vocation à rester sur
le territoire et que même je vais aller
plus loin que vous et on va peut-être
parler de la priorité nationale c'est
intéressant c'est un vrai sujet de
clivage et je pense qu'on assume toutes
les deux sur le fait que les personnes
de la même manière qu'ils ont des titres
de séjour qui arrive à expiration qui
n'ont plus d'emploi de manière durable
sur le territoire n'ont pas non plus
vocation à rester sur le territoire je
vois pas en quoi tout cela revient à
diviser les français c'est simplement un
contrôle et une règle gré lac de
régulation drastique de l'immigration et
c'est ce que disait votre propre
mouvement dans les années 90 est ce que
disait alain juppé dans les années 90
d'abord moi je reprends tout ce que
disait mon mouvement gaulliste le rpr
dont vous pouvez pas vraiment vous
prétendre l'héritière parce que quand on
réhabilite mais j'étais un homme je pars
je n'étais pas abbassi vous br aux
accords comme vous n'y était pas vous
venez sur evolis vous n'êtes pas leurs
héritières moi je suis leurs héritières
jeu reprend exactement ce que disait
charles pasqua à l'époque c'est à dire
plus de droit du sol automatique mais on
demande la nationalité française à 18
ans et ont fait la preuve de son
assimilation parce que la nationalité
française c'est précieux et ça se
demande mais la vraie différence entre
vous et moi c'est que moi je pense que
la france elle se choisit elle se mérite
elles s'aiment mais je veux pas
l'immigration zéro je veux l'immigration
contre les jeudis pas aux étudiants
étrangers vous viendrez plus en france
je dis pas qu'il y aura plus
d'immigration de travail boris johnson
il a essayé un il a essayé en angleterre
il a tenu trois mois il n'y avait plus
personne pour conduire les camions
proches le sujet aujourd'hui c'est des
quotas par métier par pays et je
revendique de dire ce que tous les pays
posent pas les mêmes problèmes et que on
a aujourd'hui des pays avec lesquels on
a des très très bonne relation il ya
aucun problème migratoire avec et il ya
des pays avec lesquels on a des
problèmes le mali par exemple le mali
nos soldats 58 soldats morts qui ont
payé le prix du sang au mali 58 soldats
et les maliens refusent de reprendre
leur clandestins bas et ben on dira 0
visa pour le mali ou alors parce qu'on
peut pas à la fois payé le prix du sang
aider au développement du mali à voir le
mali qui reprend 0 clandestins et leur
donner des visas mais c'est pas la même
chose le mali et d'autres pays qui ne
posent aucun problème qui le jeu
complètement le jeu donc moi je crois
pas à l'immigration zéro comme vous et
j'ai entendu eric zemmour alors vous
vous avancez un peu masqué madame
maréchal si je peux me permettre
si
madame marchal et renoncent masqué quand
ils respectent pas le peine un peu
maréchal un peu maréchal alors ce soir
c'est marion maréchal un juste marichal
un peu extrêmes ont accédé temps en
temps pas vraiment alors marion maréchal
on a le jeu mais je peux pas répondre à
ça parce que je trouve ça t'as juste qui
nourrit nous reste et vous on a on avait
convenu ensemble vous restiez est-ce que
vous avez une dernière question posée
parce que je saute pas vous mais tu en
voilà mais j'aimerais bien répondre là
dessus parce que je les y répondez moi
il ya des longs déroulement mais c'est
il ya beaucoup d'éléments dans ce que
vous avez dit donc c'est pour ça que
c'est intéressant mais je vois à chaque
fois là la posture qui consiste à se
cacher derrière les migrations de
travail mais vous savez malheureusement
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement
d'ailleurs l'immigration de travail
représente une part relativement faible
de l'immigration qui arrivent légalement
en france puisque sur de mémoire les 3,3
millions de stocks de titre de séjour
qui a aujourd'hui sur le territoire
c'est à peu près autour de 7% qui relève
véritablement de l'immigration de
travail donc si vous voulez moi je veux
bien que vous vous arquebouté sur la
question des migrations de travail pour
dire que réguler l'immigration de ce
point de vue là c'est ridicule mais en
fait le vrai sujet il n'est pas là
pardon et vous le savez je pense très
bien il suffit pour la pour cela de lire
le livre de votre directeur de campagne
patrick stefanini qui explique ça très
bien et qui y voit que la première
problématique aujourd'hui c'est aussi le
dévoiement de filières d'immigration
notamment le droit d'asile mais aussi
d'ailleurs malheureusement les filières
étudiante et je pense que là dessus il
ya un vrai clivage c'est vrai il ya un
vrai clivage et c'est intéressant je
pense que là dessus on peut y aller
alors vous allez dire que je suis
d'extrême droite que je joue entre le
pen et maréchal s'est passé un peu là la
facilité de l'argumentation ce soir mais
sur la priorité nationale aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que eric zemmour défend le
fait que les associations les dires les
contributions sociales les aides
sociales pardon non contributives je
vais y arriver soit réservé aux
personnes n'étaient française et ça
comprend les allocations familiales les
allocations logement le rsa dans votre
programme que j'ai lu attentivement vous
dites je conditionne les allocations
familiales ou m'arrêter si je me trompe
et les allocations des deux logements au
fait qu'il y ait une condition de
résidence de cinq ans et c'est vrai
gruyère régulière régulier évidemment et
baekeland est évidemment évidemment mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que est-ce que
selon vous il est suffisant que des
personnes aient simplement résider sur
le territoire sans jamais avoir d
serment travailler sans jamais avoir
nécessairement contribué que par
ailleurs vous ne vous ne vous excluez
donc du coup le rsa ça veut dire que
demain on étrangers qui arrivent sur le
territoire qui ne travaille pas c'est
déjà le cas pour les arrêter à ces cinq
ans non mais adacore 50 dans les
violences régulières oui mais justement
ce que vous dites c'est que jade vous ça
vous ça vous suffit c'est ça que jeanne
va vous dire qui est ce que la condition
de résidence est une condition
suffisante quand on voit les difficultés
aujourd'hui sociale de nos compatriotes
quand on voit le coup l'immigration
ou à l'année est-ce qu'il vous semble
pas judicieux de réserver la solidarité
nationale aux personnes de nationalité
française moi je crois que quand on
vient en france et qu'on s'intègre moi
je veux pas qu'on vienne en france pour
toucher des allocations familiales ou
des allocations sociales je veux qu'on
vienne pour travailler je me conviennent
pour s'intégrer mais là bas on attendra
donc dans votre résidence vous n'avez
pas pardon vous n'avez pas répondu sur
les étudiants moi je suis pour la
sélection à l'entrée à l'université donc
je veux aussi que les étudiants qu'on
accueille sa voile et soit des étudiants
puissent être très sélectionnés mais on
va pas fermer nos universités aux
étudiants étrangers naissante sur le
regroupement familial social des
migrantes 5 milliards et voyez moi je
souhaite qu'il soit plus automatique et
je souhaite qu'il y ait des conditions
de français je souhaite qu'on passe un
examen de français est-ce qu'on peut pas
s'intégrer et on peut pas élever ses
enfants correctement il ne peut pas
travailler si on parle pas le français
et qu'on donne des garanties
d'assimilation donc oui je suis très
fermé je voulais simplement la condition
servile suffit c'est ça que je pose
comme je trouve que quand on apprend
dans cinq ans respecter les lois
françaises oui on suppose d'avoir les
mêmes droits fait vivre que les autres à
respecter respecter les lois françaises
mais rentré à la france je pense est
important mais juste vous remarquerez
cyril hanouna occupants de marion
maréchal-le pen ne m'a pas répondu sur
est-ce que lé dakor avèk iv l'eczéma
vais pas sur la haine de l'islam vous
connaissez le mieux sur la manière on
accomplit islam et islamisme c'est la
même à la hausse
réponse sur l'islam il s'est mis à jouer
on va fait un peu loin dit il alors des
gorges lui non non parce que moi je
serai au second tour non mais
[Applaudissements]
soyons présents dans la maison régnant
dans la fiction la même chose moi je ne
confonds pas les musulmans avec les
islamistes jamais je ne les confondre et
c'est ce qui fait la différence entre
l'extrême droite et la droite mais
madame
sortir un quart d'heure si vous
voir ya les
jeux qui ont paralysé en mêlant musique
ou et je conclus là-dessus non écoutez
moi je vais vous dire je suis très à
l'aise là dessus en effet l'islamisme et
une lecture fondamentaliste de l'islam
vous le savez je pense que personne ici
on imagine que les djihadistes sont des
bouddhistes radicaliser un se sont
malgré tout des musulmans radicaliser
donc il est évident qu'il y a
aujourd'hui un lien dire que ça se
confond totalement de fait il ya
évidemment une différence puisqu'il ya
une lecture fondamentaliste dire que ça
n'a rien à voir ça me semble aussi un
petit peu un petit peu délicat et
compliqué après c'est vrai que je pense
qu'il ya une à une il ya une vraie
différence aujourd'hui entre nous alors
vous allez dire c'est la différence
entre la droite et d'extrême droite que
c'est votre argument ce soir mais au
delà de la question de l'iran - la
différence entre moi eric zemmour c'est
la différence sur la question de
l'islamisme sur la lutte contre
l'islamisme dont je pense que façon ça
fait l'unanimité dans le globalement
dans la vie politique française mais ce
qui est vrai c'est que ce que je crois
et sur la question de l'immigration
notamment et c'est vrai que je n'entends
pas cette dimension civilisationnelle
dans votre discours c'est que demain si
l'islam est majoritaire en france et
nous avons une majorité de compatriotes
ou deux personnes qui sont de
nationalité de conduire de confession
musulmane sur le territoire français à
la pieuvre est à l'honneur si vous
voulez de confession musulmane sur le
sur le territoire français
permettez moi de me dire que le visage
de la france va complètement changer ça
mais c'est l'info des vraies bonnes
réponses avec des
mots doux ça vous pose un problème que
demain l'islam potentiellement sont
majoritaires en france où est ce que
pour vous c'est pas un sujet toute façon
les peuples sont interchangeables c'est
une question de religion c'est du privé
mais madame le pen est ce que c'est un
débat d'extrême droite avait madame le
pen vraiment vous avez l'art de ne pas
répondre ne pas répondre à la vraie qui
ne pas répondre avec six mois je vais
répondre alors alors répondu aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce que je souhaite c'est que
on est une vraie politique de régulation
des flux migratoires et qu'on ait une
vraie c'est pas mal de co développement
de l'afrique 6 mars grâce à faire mais
ça permet aujourd'hui c'est pas avec des
sioux
annoncé très important ma question c'est
le crapaud est ce qu'on lui demande si
l'islam est majoritaire en france vous
considérez que c'est un sujet où ça
n'est pas un sujet que ça changera
strictement rien que finalement c'est
pas un enjeu ici c'est ma théorie
complotiste de la peur et de la haine
qui permet qui vous permet d'exister et
qui vous permet aujourd'hui
de essayer de fédérer
c'est vrai
c'est parti les théories complotistes
qui ne baisse pas incendies sont là
elles sont la panne est mieux pour faire
peur et que pour susciter la cc pour sa
réelle complotistes en france 66 % des
français considèrent que le grand
emplacement est une réalité il ya
aujourd'hui vraie réalité il ya une
vraie réalité de l'immigration
aujourd'hui incontrôlées donc tous et
pour ça je lutte contre et c'est pour ça
que patrick stefanini que vous citez est
aujourd'hui directeur de ma campagne et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on est en
train de même cible à 6 on est en train
de même air china effectué une vraie
politique pour lutter contre merci
niveau théorie il nous resterait à la
seconde agence vos théories ne sait
si marion maréchal